It does not lie within any of our remits to
be entirely sane. There are so many powerful
reasons why we must lack an entirely even
keel. We have complex histories, we are heading
towards the ultimate catastrophe, we are vulnerable
to devastating losses; love will never go
wholly well, the gap between our hopes and
our realities will be cavernous. In the circumstances,
what we should aim for is not sanity, but
a wise, knowledgeable and self-possessed relationship
to our manifold insanities, or what we might
term ‘sane insanity.’ The sane insane
differ from the simply insane by virtue of
the honest and accurate grasp they have on
what is not entirely right with them. They
may not be wholly balanced, but they don’t
have the additional folly of insisting on
their normalcy. They can admit with good grace
– and no particular loss of dignity – that
of course they are rather peculiar at a myriad
of points. They do not go out of their way
to hide from us what they get up to in the
night, in their sad moments, when anxiety
strikes, or during attacks of envy. They can
– at their best – be dryly funny about
the tragedy of being human. They lay bare
the fears, doubts, longings, desires and habits
that don’t belong to the story we like to
tell ourselves about sanity. They don’t
make ready confessions to let themselves off
the hook or to be eccentric. They simply realise
the unreasonableness of expecting to be reasonable
all the time. They warn others as far as possible
in advance of what being around them might
involve – and apologise promptly for their
failings as soon as they have manifested themselves.
They offer their friends and companions accurate
maps to their craziness, which is about the
most generous thing one can to anyone who
has to endure us. The sane-insane among us
are not a special category of the mentally
unwell: they represent the most evolved possibility
for a mature human being.Thank you for watching.
We’ve designed a tote bag to help us all
acknowledge that no one is normal, please
follow the link on your screen now to find
out more.